así es pues la idea lo que él necesita
es tener esa mayoría absoluta son 289
escaños pero por ahora según las
estimaciones tendría simplemente una
mayoría relativa esto lo que significa
es que va a tener que negociar para
poder lograr aprobar sus reformas en
especial esa reforma pensional que
digamos va a ser la reforma tal vez más
importante de estos próximos cinco años
para eso pues como les decía va a tener
que negociar y seguramente va a tener
que hacerlo con los partidos de derecha
en especial con los republicanos de esa
derecha conservadora derecha tradicional
que finalmente va a jugar un rol
importante en esta asamblea nacional y
justamente pues van a tener que van a de
alguna manera tienen digamos la sartén
por el mango todo esto precisamente
porque emanuel mccomb va a enfrentarse
de todas maneras a una oposición que va
a estar muy presente en la asamblea
nacional si se tiene en cuenta el número
de escaños que va a tener el partido de
rol y que melo solo
'francia insumisa efectivamente ahí va a
haber complicaciones sobre todo porque
entre más importante este grupo
parlamentario que tiene que ser de
mínimo 15 diputados con los ciertos que
tendrá mayor presencia y podrán imponer
también los temas en la agenda del día